Use this bind off anytime you're ending
your knitting with needles out of work.
You might be working
a tuck lace pattern like this one
with some needles out of work.
Now, notice my needle arrangement.
I have every third needle
in work with two needles out of work.
Let's consider binding
off in this needle arrangement.
I'm using a 'round the gate peg method.
I'll position my working yarn
around the gate peg to the right
of the stitch that I'm binding off.
I'll pull the yarn through the stitch,
keeping that extra loop
around the gate peg.
Pull up a loop.
Next, I'll position my latch tool
in the empty space that was created from
the needle out of work, and I'll just
pull up a loop, creating a chain.
Position the tool in the next space,
keeping keeping the working yarn around
that gate peg, and chain another loop.
Bind off the next stitch
by putting it on the latch tool,
grab the working yarn with the hook
and pull it through the stitch.
Keep that working yarn around
the next gate peg, chain in the next
space, and repeat for the second space,
and then bind off the stitch.
Each time before you create a chain
or bind off a stitch,
position the working yarn
around that gate peg for extra stretch.
The bind off edge is worked
around the gate pegs.
When done, pop off those loops
from the gate pegs and you'll have
a beautiful, stretchy edge
that accommodates the ladders that were
created by the needles out of work.